Peugeot has given its 508 series of
facelift both technically and in terms
of design the all road models been given
an even more striking front end we're
taking the 508 rxh diesel hybrid out for
a spin the 2-liter engine packs 120
kilowatts under the hood with support at
the rear axle from a 27 kilowatt
electric motor that means the rxh can go
100 kilometers on only 4 litres of
diesel
the radiator grill is even more steeply
raked but the lion emblem is still what
catches the eye
although the rxh looks like a tough
off-road station wagon the base version
is really very sumptuously and
luxuriously equipped for instance the
panoramic sunroof comes as standard
the other special features of the 508
rxh are higher road clearance striking
running lights and coated wheel wells in
addition to chrome trim on the front and
rear bumpers
we're testing a car with a six-speed
Automatic transmission which boosts the
508 rxh hybrid to 100 kilometres an hour
in 8.5 seconds
it has a maximum speed of 213 km/h the
starting price for a basic rxh hybrid is
forty-three thousand six hundred and
fifty euros in Germany
shada finding our test driver Matta
squad says it's a shame that the hybrid
only has a power consumption indicator
rather than a standard tachometer and
the steering is typically French meaning
you can still feel the road even though
it's not as stiff as other cars
nevertheless in terms of driving the
automatic transmission takes too long to
switch between gears Matty says the car
is already a bit ponderous and the
transmission makes a quick getaway even
less likely even after su won't be
hindered mine rushes for comment Suzette
leash the hybrid drive technology is
located under the floor of the cargo
area this is where the electric motor
and batteries are housed that turn the
car into an all wheel drive vehicle
no space is sacrificed to make the car a
hybrid the storage areas volume ranges
from four hundred to one thousand three
hundred and sixty liters that means when
rear seats have been folded down the rxh
has about two hundred and forty liters
less cargo space than the classic diesel
version a plus point however is the
flush cargo Lib at the rear
Matis says the interior is well done all
the materials are soft and the
touchscreen display is better here than
in other purges some he says are
extremely reflective this one is
relatively easy to read even when
there's plenty of light coming through
the panoramic roof which is another one
of his favorite features and there's
more
the rxh isn't just luxurious it's chock
full of helpful gizmos front and rear
parking assist cruise control and a
blind spot assistants are available in
the standard version
and the driver can shift using paddles
on the steering wheel
also standard are heated seats for the
driver and front-passenger
the blend of off-road ruggedness and
interior comfort is impressive but the
hybrid drivetrain is only available in
the rather expensive rxh version of the
508
not it says he likes the new front end
of the Peugeot 508 far more than the old
one whether the car is a sedan a station
wagon all the rxh and the hybrid version
stacks up well in terms of what it
offers in fuel savings yet the vehicle
is exorbitantly priced he says in fact
it may be worth it to look at a diesel
or even a less economical
gasoline-powered model Ben Cena